Hello, this is Mario Aquino and you're watching
another episode of Strange Loop chats.
With me today is Hillel Wayne.
Before we get started, I'd like to say a few
things about Strange Loop this year, which
is going to run in St. Louis from Thursday,
September 30th through Saturday, October the
2nd.
Tickets for in-person and virtual attendance
are available through the web site.
In addition to a Strange Loop conference and
workshops, tickets are also available for
TLA+ conference, which is being held at St.
Louis Union Station alongside the Strange
Loop workshops on Thursday, September 30th.
For more information, please visit thestrangeloop.com
With that out of the way let me introduce
Hillel Wayne.
For anyone not familiar with him or with TLA+
let me say that Hillel spoke at Strange Loop
in 2017, where he gave a talk titled &quot;Tackling
Concurrency Bugs with TLA+.&quot; Viewers
can watch that talk on this YouTube channel.
Hillel, thank you for sitting with me for
this interview.
Pleasure to be here.
How can I help you?
For anyone not familiar with TLA+ can you
give us kind of a summary?
What is TLA+?
So let's actually start with a bit of the
bigger picture first.
Okay.
Software correctness.
We need to be able to write software that
we wanna be able to write it quickly.
We want to be able to write cheaply, want
to be able to write it that it's correct,
right?
Generally, there are multiple different kinds
of bugs.
The most common kinds of bugs are what we
might call implementation details, where you
are essentially writing something and you
mess something up.
You put something in the wrong place, you're
coding something, and you make a small mistake.
Those are the things that we try to catch
with our type systems, our code review, our
testing, et cetera.
I'm sure you're familiar with all of that.
Now there's another class of bugs broadly
that we can think of as design bugs, where
you are implementing something correctly,
but the thing you're implementing, doesn't
do what you want it to do.
Maybe it fundamentally has a race condition
just built into the core essence there, or
maybe it doesn't actually satisfy your requirements
in all cases or maybe there is one execution
which causes to shut down all servers.
And you can't really say that that's a bug
because it's actually part of the implementation.
It's part of the features.
So these are the bugs that are a lot rarer,
but they're also the ones that are much more
dangerous.
They tend to be harder to attack.
They tend to blow up much more nastily in
production and fixing them tends to take a
lot more time because you have to fundamentally
redesign your system.
The problem with trying to solve these things
with like tests and types and checking and
such as that, those all work on the code level.
They work on an existing implementation and
these are issues you want to find before you
have the implementation so you don't spend
weeks and weeks implementing the wrong thing.
This leads to a class of tools we call formal
specification languages, which are languages
you can use to express abstract models of
a system and catch these design bugs before
you have to start coding them.
TLA+ is one of the tools in this, and right
now rapidly becoming the most popular one
due to accessibility and its power.
It was sort of catapulted to the main stage
by Amazon Web Services when they published
a paper about how they found critical bugs
in S3 and Dynamo DB using this, bugs that
passed all of their current error corrections
systems and only took them like a few weeks.
A weekend in one case of practice to find
that sort of got a lot more people into it,
including me, I used it at a small education
startup where it probably saved us months
and tens or hundreds of thousands of dollars.
And that got me excited to start talking about
it more publicly.
The approach that TLA+ takes for doing, I
guess, specification testing is through expressing
specifications in, the language of TLA+?
Yes.
one way to sort of think about that is that
imagine you're trying to implement, I don't
know, like querying a database, right?
At the really, really high level it's just
data's here, it is now in this value.
At the actual mutation level, you have all
of your like classes, you have your structures,
you have this entire control flow, you have
audits, you have error checking, you have
probably a logging in there somewhere.
You probably have some kind of dependency
injection, so you can swap in and out different
kinds of database.
And so what could be hundreds or thousands
of lines of implementation code can at the
really high abstract level be one or two lines
of modeling code.
That actually sounds really remarkable and
I guess I would ask how is it that things
that are, I guess, components of distributed
systems can be represented with such little
amount of modeling code?
Because fundamentally the idea here is that
we're looking at the design, we're looking
at sort of trying to find these, these less
common, but much more critical issues that
exist at a much higher, more fundamental level
of the system.
So we can essentially abstract away all of
these implementation details, that stuff that's
necessary to make the system work on computers,
but isn't really part of our abstract machine,
our essential machine, as you might think
of it,
Are there any kind of formal specification
languages that TLA+ either builds on or relies
on or changes or improves upon?
Yes.
A little bit about the history of like this
entire space.
There was a few different branches that mostly
started, Vienna Development Method of IBM
in I believe the late 1960s.
And then there was some sort of, some offshoots
of that, primarily Zed, there was a separate
branch called linear temporal logic, which
by which was basically designed to model,
essentially create a mathematical representation
of how things can change.
And then essentially TLA+ is a synthesis of
one branch of temporal logic called temporal
logic of actions with ideas from Zed and a
few other places I believe.
So time is a component of the specification,
I guess the focus of the modeling that you
can do with the specification language.
Yeah, the way we sort of think about systems
is that we have all the things the system
can do.
It could say, send a message, or it could
drop a message or could the queue could be
reordering the messages or something could
receive a message.
And then every possible execution of those
actions, every possible like sequence of states
that the system could go through is called
the behavior.
Then there is exists, the set of all possible
behaviors this system can do and what we want
to guarantee using these languages, by inspecting
the properties, is that every single possible
behavior satisfies our high level requirements.
Yeah.
There are other different, there are other
different like models of like how we specify
and like how we represent models of systems.
This is the TLA+ way, which tends to be very
good with, you have to deal with any kind
of concurrency distributed systems.
It's less good for other things.
And it's really a matter of choosing what
your problem domain is.
Can you kind of give a, an example of the
kind of flaw that's I guess maybe behavior
oriented that TLA+ would be able to catch
in a distributed system.
So in the, in the &quot;Tackling Concurrency
Bugs With TLA+&quot; talk I gave at Strange
Loop, I gave some examples of how we used
it at my old workplace.
And one of the examples was what's called
the batch installer, where we essentially
had to be moving a lot of resources across
a lot of different iPads, essentially like
app resources that we had a finite number
of.
But we were working through a system where
we moved them through by large batch APIs,
but this third-party system we had to work
through was both eventually consistent and
non idempotent.
So if we essentially sent a message saying,
do this, it would be a while before the physical
world reflected that reality and a while before
their system reflected that reality.
And also by non-idempotent, it means that
if like we were in that space where we said,
Hey, do this.
And we said, Hey, do this again.
It would trigger a memory leak.
If we were lucky would trigger a memory leak,
it could do other much worse things.
So we had to build a system that guaranteed
all resources were eventually in the right
places while also guaranteeing that we never
sent an, a request that would trigger a memory
leak by being non-idempotent, given that there
was a delay between when the real world reflected
what their system was and what their system
was telling us.
I see.
Yeah.
So a lot of places this can go wrong.
And, a couple of the sprints before we started
using formal modeling did have major issues
where in specific circumstances, it can either
break idempotency or break the requirement
and a resource would just be left on the table.
But we were able to sort of use TLA+ to essentially
create a model of a system that the first
model ended up having like a 19 step error
trace where like these 19 things would go
wrong.
We would like enter this loop where something
would just not get moved around and that we
can make a fix on that.
And then thefix would turn out to like have
a different issue.
So we'd rethink like the design and eventually
we were able to find a design after like a
couple of days of modeling that guaranteed
all the properties we needed.
It also gave us enough insight into what you
need to do that actually building the system
ended up taking like a couple of weeks faster
than we expected.
Hmm.
So, considering what you were just describing,
can you, I guess, say a little bit about where
TLA+ fits in a development cycle?
Yeah.
So there's a few different ways people use
it.
This is actually more interesting question
because given that this kind of formal specification
tool sort of doesn't really have any analogs
in mainstream development.
It's a, it's like a very large field.
There's like a lot of like, isn't it, but
they're not like very common tools.
And because they solve an issue that really
isn't solved by anything else when people
sort of do start using these tools, they end
up using them in a lot of different ways that
they might not necessarily be the best use
of that may not be the best tools to do that,
but because there's nothing else out there
they're best creatively needs to use them
if that makes sense.
Fundamentally, there's a couple of places
that are considered the &quot;proper&quot;
place to use them.
So for example, before you start like writing
a large amount of code, you model out the
systems we're going to build.
It's also often used when you're trying to
refactor existing code or like finding a bug
where you create a model of the system to
sort of figure out better where the bug is
and then make the changes you expect to make
sure that doesn't reintroduce a different
bug That said, because these tools kind of
do something that nobody really otherwise
has access to people end up using them in
a lot of different ways, sort of pushing the
limits of how they can use them.
For example, one of the earliest like creative
misuses I found was on documenting things
where you'd essentially take a system and
write an executable documentation of the entire
system and show how making changes would cause
different impacts.
I've also seen it used for people doing optimization,
where they prove an optimization would not
like introduce new bugs to have identical
behavior before actually like implementing
the optimization.
I have seen people use it as a constraint
solver or as like a model space generator
where they essentially use it to just build
out a state space and sort of see what the
state space looks like.
So there's a lot different ways you can use
it.
But the ways that the majority people use
it are either are basically before you start
implementation.
You did though describe the use of TLA+ in,
I guess, a setting once you, either, once
you have a, a working system or, maybe some
way into the development cycle for a system.
I remember either from a talk that you've
given or maybe from your book, how specifications
that are expressed with TLA+ are completely
separate from, the application code itself,
it's just a completely different thing.
And it doesn't, it's not meant to drive the
application.
Right.
It's just meant to represent states that a
system can be in given a model that describes
how the systems behaviors work.
Right.
So I, I guess one question I have is, how
is it that teams that use TLA+ can try to
keep the models that they use to specify a
system and the system itself.
How do those things remain in sync when you
have a working system, either when you have
a working system that TLA+ was used to sort
of design at the behaviors of, or, when you
have a working system and you're sort of starting
from scratch, but you get the model of specification
and the application itself sort of in sync,
but over time, the system changes and grows.
How do those things, like what are the ways
that people try to keep those things in sync?
Code review, lots and lots of code review.
Okay, more or less facetious then that, that
is one of the core limitations of these kinds
of tools is that there's no easy way to connect
them to the code.
This is often intentional.
It gives you more flexibility and makes these
tools much easier to use.
And it's generally better to get people using
a tool that is say, 10% of the effort, but
only 50% of the effectiveness versus somethingi
that's like a hundred times the effort and
twice the effectiveness kind of thing that
said there are techniques that people do use.
One of the common ones that I've seen and
I've done myself is what's called I'm not
sure there's actually a proper term for this,
but I sort of think of it as trace testing.
So what you can do is create your model, right?
And the model is set, essentially creates
a state space, right?
Of like everything that can happen in the
system.
And then what you can do is you can turn that
into say a JSON stream of actions and create
what's called an orchestrator on your code
that reads in this JSON and makes the corresponding
moves in your system, say it sees, okay, so
this writer will do this thing.
So we all send a message to this writer and
have it make this like operation.
Then essentially what happens is you then
check that what the system does it, what?
Sorry, what your code does matches what the
abstract TLA+ model does modulo like translation
between the data layers.
I've seen this actually used really, really
effectively at some places, the main downside
is that you kind of have to handroll for the
particular system you're working on so we
can't make any general third-party libraries
or at least nobody has.
Yeah.
I guess figuring out a way for, the specification
to either drive system level tests, or to
use the specification to confirm that the
system behaves as the model expects it to,
I feel like those things would be like having
some, some approach for, tackling those problems
would help teams use the tool in a way so
that there's not a lot of divergence between
the two, right?.
I should, emphasize though that while divergence
can happen, it's also, it can be solved at
the human level with like process better processes
and more fundamentally, I think it is important
to note that while this isn't like, well,
this would take like what we can do with this
stuff to the next level, what we can do currently,
even with like code and spec diverging is
still much, much, much more valuable than
we can do without it.
It would make it, it would make a good thing
great.
It wouldn't make an unacceptable thing acceptable,
if that makes sense.
Mm.
Yeah.
So, as I've been thinking about TLA+, like
one of the things that occurred to me was,
whether TLA+ is either like a proofer or a
compiler for, state machines that represent
distributed systems.
Would you say that that that's a fair analogy?
Um, I would not.
So the first thing I wanna mention here is
that there is actually a language that sort
of you write specifications and it compiles
them to actual state machine code.
The most famous in this category is actually
P as in P, as in Papa, by Microsoft research,
which essentially creates C-sharp code based
on abstract set state machine specifications,
TLA+ itself is just essentially a notation
for describing systems.
Then we have model checkers or proof systems
that then take those models of the system
and verify that they have properties.
So I guess the, the main, the main like thing
I actually want to relate it to is Z3, but
that's probably not very useful either because
that's also like a tool in this space.
So I guess maybe the best way to describe
it would essentially be like a configuration
language that generates a test suite.
But that's like, honestly, I it's honestly
hard to come up with good analogies here because
this is like a tool that like does something
we don't really do otherwise.
So like all the analogies in some way end
up breaking down a bit,
Yeah, that's, that's not uncommon, right,
where you've got analogies that are leaky
in one way or another to try to just communicate
an idea, especially one that's sort of novel
and unlike other things, too.
Where is it that folks can learn more about
TLA+?
So, first of all, if you are coming to Strange
Loop, we still have like space open for, the
TLA+ conference, which happens the day before,
So there are essentially three resources.
Actually before I did, um, the Strange Loop
talk, I was so excited about this that I wrote
an online documentation, learntla.com. that
one I was updating from about like 2017 to
2018.
I'm currently a little bit unsatisfied with
it and both, but I haven't had to update it
because afterwards I got a book deal to write
Practical TLA+, and I think this is currently
the best introduction to TLA+, a lot of pedagogy
went into it.
It is full of practical examples of how to
write, basically how to write specs, how to
actually apply it to business problems, how
to use it for like modeling requirements or
distributed systems or data structures, et
cetera.
I currently think that's the strongest one.
I don't think it'll be the strongest as of
2022, because I'm going to take the stuff
I learned in the past four years to like,
completely revamp learntla.com and I'm scheduled
to start doing that in my planner, starting
2022.
Um, and then finally, if you want to sort
of go to the source and like learn the canonical
text to like learn fundamentally what's going
on versus something more focused on getting
you applying it, there are &quot;Specifying
Systems&quot; by Leslie Lamport.
This is actually free too, if you download
the TLA+ Toolbox, it is included as a free
PDF and it's a little bit more advanced and
I think it requires a bit more like mathematical,
like comfort with mathematical ability, and
approaches it sort of in a bit of a different
way, but it also like is the reference text
that people use to like, understand how the
system works and like how to resolve certain
questions.
So Hillel, I want to thank you for sitting
with me for this interview.
It's been really enjoyable talking to you,
for anyone watching this video as I mentioned
at the beginning, if you're interested in
Strange Loop conference, tickets are available
for both in-person and virtual attendance.
workshop day for the conference is going to
be Thursday, September 30th.
That's the same day as the TLA+ conference.
And I would like to point, and I would like
to point out that if you're not going to the
TLA+ conference, Saul Pwanson is going to
have a really cool, um, workshop on VisiData,
which is essentially like a Vim for spreadsheets.
It is an extremely cool piece of technology.
You should definitely check it out.
Thank you for watching.
Hillel thanks again for sitting for the interview.
Thank you for having me.